today i'll be doing my insane and the
end game lecture
uh and i wanted to do it on this game
between
alexinko and grishok from the candidates
tournament this year
i'm gonna you i'd like to use lots of
candidate games because
they're just kind of nice games to use
but also
it's like the main slow tournament
that's happened and in general
i think you know classical chess
tournaments like these are the games
where you can learn the most from
because it's fun to follow the rapid and
the blitz especially live i i really
enjoy it and i like watching those
tournaments
uh and of course blitz and stuff like
that can be really fun to watch but it's
also
how do i put this i guess like it's
harder to learn from the games because
oftentimes they are
there are lots of blunders and things
like this which is cool to watch and
it's
it's entertaining but i would say games
like this are very very instructive to
go over
slowly and to take your time on so i
really enjoy looking at these games
and this one had quite an interesting
end game
that it featured with chances for both
sides and just really really exciting
and i also partially chose this game
because in the future i'm going to be
doing an arena
with for the chess twitch stream
and for that i am going to kind of have
everyone play from
a position in this game and that's kind
of
a cool concept and i thought this game
would be good for that because it is a
double-edged position where both sides
have chances so it's kind of a nice
position to play from
uh in any case welcome everyone i am
monitoring the youtube chat
let me just type so you know i'm here um
so if you guys do say things
i'm mostly going to be lecturing but i
will ask questions and i will be looking
for your answers hey chess king
uh and hi anyone else uh who is here
so let's start i suppose with the
opening which is not a usual thing i do
in in-game lectures
but the opening actually directly leads
to an end game which i find is actually
is very very interesting
so alexinko plays e4 it's a french
defense
grishok just so you guys have some
background knowledge to the game if you
weren't following the candidates first
of all it's a great tournament to follow
i always recommend
but i would say that alexinko was
already
like tied for last or close so he didn't
really have any shot to try to win
whereas grishok i believe had lost his
previous game and the only way he could
ever hope to fight for first was to win
so grishok really had to win this game
whereas for like cinco
it was less of a must win and more of
just a normal tournament game
so just for some background so that's
part of why probably grishok
chose the french instead of a maybe more
solid opening although to be fair he
does play sharply with black anyway and
the french is one of his main weapons
not main weapons i guess the night off
is probably more of a main weapon
uh all right i did uh
so knight f6 e5 knight d7
f4 and i just wanted to go over the
opening because it's quite an
interesting one so c596 bishop e3
and then cd94 so in this position
there's a main line right and that one
goes with bishop c5 and then there are
many different options but it usually
goes queen d2
and then either castles or a6 b5 at some
point and things like this so it goes
something like this
and it's very complic very complex and
these positions are very very
complicated to understand but
it does offer chances for both sides but
this isn't how grieschuk
intended to do it he actually played the
move queen b6 here
and this move is extremely double edged
in many ways
and it leads to a very unbalanced
position because it kind of forces white
to sacrifice a pawn
and i would say that at the very top
level they trot out this line once in a
while when they want to surprise their
opponent
because it's one of those lines where if
you've reviewed it recently and have a
new idea
you can have a big edge over someone who
hasn't looked at it and it's very likely
that ike cinco hadn't reviewed this line
quite as recently as grishok had so it's
kind of a nice surprise weapon if you're
trying to win
but of course it's risky because you're
going to grab this b2 pawn
so because of the pin on the knight on
d4 white has no choice but to play queen
d2
queen takes b2 rook b1
queen a3 and now there are
a few options but the main move is
actually to play bishop b5 so basically
white's not trying to do anything
immediate they're just trying to develop
their pieces and get an initiative
so a move like knight cb5 looks quite
natural
and it looks like oh i'm going to fork
you on c7 but the problem is queen takes
a2
hits the rook on b1 so this means that
it's not possible
all right welcome dallas salute all
right
so bishop b5 instead was played which is
quite normal
and yes for those just joining this is
not an endgame yet but it will become an
end game very soon
so in this position believe it or not
you can actually play the move knight
db8 and i remember for a very brief time
this was actually a thing this was a
major thing
but it looks very unnatural and of
course white has potential for a huge
initiative here
when you play a move like this so
instead black takes and plays a6 which
is the main
idea and the whole point is that you're
actually going to sacrifice this b7 pawn
bishop takes d7 check
and taking with the king's a bit
suicidal i would not recommend it so
they take with the bishop
and now there's a nice little finesse if
you try to take the b7 pawn immediately
then bishop b4 is kind of a nice move
and the whole idea is that black's a
little
like not quite ready to castle yet
because d7 hangs but they can play rook
c8 they can play bishop c6 or bishop c8
they have lots of options and this is
not really what white wants
so it's very important you actually
attack the queen first
and the whole point is that there is no
really great square
to warm you up a little bit e7 is what
was played in the game which is the main
move and the reason why is because of
queen
a5 something very unfortunate happens to
you so just to make sure you guys are
paying attention what happens to black
if you play queen a5
just to see if we got people who are
alive in the audience i always like to
ask these questions first
anyone if i don't get an answer in a
minute or so i'll just show you but
i always like to give you guys a chance
uh ah oh hey doug by the way uh
i'm reading the youtube chat i did not
know there was another chat actually
so if there's another chat i am quite
sorry but yes
uh bishop e6 is correct
and yeah that queen is trapped so just
just making sure you guys know
uh okay so
queen e7 is the main move here rook
takes b7
and now there are two moves like queen
h4 check is what was played in the game
rook c8 is also a move here
and then usually white castles and then
black moves the queen somewhere
develops the bishop and again it's a
pretty big initiative for white but
positionally black's doing well and
that's kind of the whole point that's
why it's a double-edged position because
you can see black has the two bishops
and the c pawn is quite weak on c2
whereas black's pawn structure is nice
but of course black lacks in development
so
it's the big battle of can you use your
initiative if you can't use your
initiative
sometimes in the long term black can
even be better but black can also get
absolutely destroyed if they're not
careful
so it's one of those where you have to
be on your toes for both sides and it's
why grushrook chose this
for a must-win game as black so
queen h4 check was instead played and
here
almost everyone plays the move bishop f2
and which makes sense when you're trying
to keep an initiative right you want to
keep pieces on the board you attack the
queen
queen goes back to d8 and now usually
white plays the move bishop b6
and the idea now is that black doesn't
really want to play queen h4 now
with the bishop on b6 it's going to be
kind of annoying to ever do anything so
you play queen c8
rook c7 and then queen back to d8
believe it or not
and then white can of course repeat and
draw that's the one drawing line here
but you can also play queen d4
and this line is just a mess like this
position is so complicated
and it's been analyzed to death but
alexinko had a very different idea here
which was to play queen f2
and at first this seems like a bad idea
because you're trying to play for the
end game
when you're the one who depends on
initiative in this kind of position
white's the one who needs to play for
initiative because positionally in the
long term they're worse
but one of the misconceptions i find
that people have about the end game
is that the initiative means so much
less than the middle game yes you don't
get
mated usually or at least not horribly
so
but the initiative can still be very
very powerful in an endgame
and still be very relevant so i would
say that
the fact that white's gonna have an
initiative that carries over to the end
game doesn't mean that queen f2 is
actually that bad
so uh black in
does take on f2 bishop e7 is kind of a
more natural move in some ways because
you're trying to develop
and not give up a tempo but the problem
with this is that now white can choose
to play g3
and after queen h3 even a move like king
d2 is annoying
so you're trying to get the rook on h1
into the game with rook hb1
and the king still can't castle because
the bishop on d7 would hang so you have
to play
something i'm not exactly sure what they
would try here but it's very difficult
to find
a reasonable move i feel because you'd
like to play a move like bishop c6 but
then i play rook c7 and you've actually
accomplished nothing
uh and bishop c8 is just very very risky
i think
uh even sax on e7 become viable
sometimes
in general i would be very very worried
uh with the
i would be very very worried with the
black pieces here so it's very
understandable that grishok
took on f2 and i don't know how much
this was prepped by either side but i
feel like a move like queen f2 you would
have to repair because
trading the queens does feel like
something that's not so easy
so king takes f2 bishop to e7
and here i think that alexinko makes a
mistake
and starts to let grishok really into
the game very well so
he plays an idea which i feel is a very
nice positional idea and i know exactly
what he's going for
but it's also extremely slow and one of
the things i find is that when you're in
a position where
you're trying to play for initiative
like in this position white needs to
have an initiative here right because in
the long term
positionally black's doing quite well
with the two bishops in the backwards c
pawn
so white tries to play a positional idea
but to me this does not feel like a
position where you should do that
this is more in my eyes a position where
you should be trying to actually still
play tactically
and aggressively so what move comes to
mind for you guys for white because a
move just leaps to mind for me and
for the life of me i can't figure out
what's wrong with the move
what would you guys think of playing
here with white because i again to me it
just
rooked to a7 but rook a7 has the same
drawback right if you try to move rook
a7
then i'll play rook takes rook and
castle and the problem you have here
is that you've traded off some pieces
and dulled your initiative a little bit
so the rook is going to probably come
out to c8 next for example
and it's just not going to be very
pleasant for you so i would say that
when you have such an active rook like
the beautiful rook on b7
regardless of whether you're playing for
initiative right away or not you don't
want to trade that off that
rook for the passive rook on a8 almost
never do you want to do this
so yeah rook hb1 is what all of you guys
would probably play really quickly right
late i think that's what i would play
it's probably what alexinko would play
and this is one of those cases where the
dangers of playing classical chess where
you sometimes have too much time to
think
because i think that either it was
something prepared which i just don't
really understand or
it was just like you've got too much
time to think and you overthink the
position
just play rook hd1 and b1 and i feel
like white has good chances here because
black just doesn't have a great way to
untangle with these bishops so for
example i thought about bishop d8
but now you can play rook b8 takes takes
and castles
but you're still quite tied up here so
for example after rook b7
bishop c6 you can play the move rook a7
and that pawn is still
quite juicy on a6 just kind of waiting
and i don't know this still looks quite
quite dangerous
to me at least for black
maybe back here playing bishop c8 would
be a bit better
but even here you can play rook back to
b6 for instance castles and even just a
building move like king e3 just to
improve your king position and it's just
hard for what black to play like you can
play bishop
d8 you can play bishop d7 but then rook
back to b7 right
and it's just it's really annoying like
you just don't have that many moves
so even though technically white's
allowed black to castle there's still
some initiative here and i feel like
this position would actually be very
difficult to play for black
so i'm not really sure clear on why
alexinko declined to do this of course
he's you know much stronger player than
i am i'm sure he had his reasons
but at least to my eyes his move just
looks way too slow
and that move is knight d1 so to be fair
to him he has a very decent and
reasonable idea which is to play knight
e3
and then the knight on e3 is very well
placed and he's ready to play c4
and rook back out to b1 but what i don't
like about it which you guys probably
guess is that it's just
very slow and when you're in a position
where your opponent has these positional
trumps like the beautiful pawn structure
and the two bishops
you don't really want to play slow moves
unless you have to or unless the
quicker moves don't really do too much
so bishop d8 was played so grisha is
trying to
get his king castled it feels weird to
try so hard to castle in an end game
but the fact is that his king on e8 is
really badly placed because he keeps the
rook on h8 out of the game
so he wants to be able to castle in
order to get his
get his rook into the game so it's it's
funny because it's an end game
but it feels more like a middle game
still because there's so many pieces on
the board
and you find that this is true quite
often so knight e3 was played
bishop to c6 rook to b2
castles and here alexenko plays the move
bishop c5 so
i think what he didn't want was a move
like f6 being played while his king was
still on f2
and that's definitely awkward the knight
on e3 looks nice but it does block the
king from going to its really nice e3
square
so avoiding f6 is actually something
that he doesn't
he wants so he at least forces the rook
to go to the e8 square
and now he completes his idea he plays
c4
uh well g4 f5 is possible so if we're
going way back here
uh so if we go for g4 the problem is
you're still
actually not playing that quick of an
idea so even here like i don't think f5
is actually doing a whole lot so maybe i
can play my bishop d8 move again for
instance
uh maybe bishop c8 again yeah bishop c8
maybe is the move because now the rook
has to kind of go away
and the whole point is that you can play
a move like rook c7 but i can play
bishop d8 and your rook has to
to leave so probably you should retreat
with your rook either b6 or even
back to b1 b3 if you'd prefer but now
i'm able to castle and the problem is
that f5 is just not doing enough i feel
like
if you play f5 i could think about
taking although that allows knight takes
d5
but more probably i would think about
playing a move like f6
and once again your king on f2 is kind
of feeling the heat and your pieces are
a little bit miscoordinated in my
opinion
so i don't really like this idea someone
else had a really great point in the
audience which is that
doesn't c4 open up the bishop on c6 and
that's absolutely true
so c4 in some ways is a double-edged
move but it's also trading off a very
very bad weakness on this on
the c pawn and i would also say that it
activates the knight
so because of these two factors i think
opening up the bishop is actually
justified here
the reason being like if d takes c4 and
i take c4 the knight can land on d6
where it's going to be a very very
powerful piece right
c3 and put the knight on d4 is a nice
idea but the problem with it is also
that it's still very slow and gives
black time so for example here i could
think about
again playing f6 and yes you can play
knight
knight c2 to d4 and the knight looks
really beautiful there
but then you also need to make sure your
epon's defended and your king's not in
danger and i think that it's you're
gonna find it's gonna be too slow
so once again speed really matters in
these positions because black has a lot
of potential with the two bishops here
so you have to be very cautious and you
have to play in a timely manner
so c4 i really like for this reason and
here once again grishok
like takes knight takes c4 this kind of
position i feel
is very much it's very safe for black
like even with a knight lens on d6
there's nothing horrible that's gonna
happen
you could play a bunch of moves here
honestly but even bishop c7 or something
doesn't feel that bad to me
and ideas of knight d6 even if you have
to take it you're not gonna really lose
with opposite bishops there probably
uh but you don't even have to right if
knight d6 you could probably play rook
b8 and the life kind of continues
but i don't know i mean i i guess here
it's very difficult to ever win is the
problem the knight on d6
is just really really really strong
so grishok decided to play the move f6
and this is very very double edged but
it's understandable because he wants to
really open up
his bishops very very well
so i guess if alexenko wanted to play
super safe he could have put his bishop
back on d4
and probably it's pretty safe for him
i don't think anything horrible is
happening but i guess i mean okay black
can play rook f8 if he wants it's not
like
it's completely dead but taking on d5 is
a really legitimate
uh idea now so this would be a safe move
but he elected to take on d5 instead
which also i think is perfectly good
e takes d5 he doesn't want to give up
his bishop of course
and now bishop d6 and this move again
has a very double-edged feel to it
because that bishop is a monster it
controls so many squares that the rooks
want to go to
that it's really quite annoying but it
also allows the pawn on d5
to start running and when the pawn on d5
starts running
it can become kind of an annoyance like
it's not going to really
it's not gonna become a queen any time
soon but it becomes a pest it just takes
away squares it opens up the pieces
and that's exactly what grushog does he
takes on e5 first
and plays d4 so this pawn again is just
very very much a pest and also it's
taking away a key square from white's
king white's king
is actually a little uncomfortable now
but the whole
the whole point here is that because the
bishop on d6 is so strong
it means that it's really hard to take
advantage like you'd love to play rook
f8 here pinning the knight but you can't
because the bishop
so it's a really interesting really
double edged position
that we have here so the rest the next
bunch of moves are
not forced but very logical they play d3
so white plays king e3 trying to hit the
pawn
and black really doesn't want to give up
this pawn it's kind of his pride and joy
now i would say
not that it's that strong but it's very
pesky and it makes it
difficult to deal with right so he plays
bishop b5
so these kind of positions are really
interesting because
like white's the one who has the
centralized king the powerful bishop on
d6 but these two bishops
it's kind of like black's looking for
coordination if black ever gets
coordinated if the bishops ever
start really attacking white's king or
supporting the d-pawn
white can get into trouble in a real
hurry because you can play something
like say
bishop g5 check followed by d2 and then
bishop a4 and all of a sudden you're
going to win a rook or something
whereas at the same time if white's
careful this bishop on d6 just makes it
so difficult for black to do anything
but i'd say that these positions are one
of those where the computer is very
unhelpful in learning them because
it's kind of like it'll just say
everything's equal right
which is nice but it doesn't really tell
you how to play this position and how to
deal with it
so it's very very tricky so i think
bishop g5 check is actually a worry for
white here
so alexinko played king e4 just
centralizing his king
he's not really in a rush to try to take
this this deep on
um although he would definitely very
much like to take it someday
so here grishok activates his rook with
rook c8
alexinko plays knight to d4
bishop to c4 and now rook d1
so white trying to centralize trying to
make sure that pawn's controlled
black's trying to keep his bishop that
bishop on c4 is actually a very very
nice piece
because it controls both pawns it kind
of keeps white's king at bay
so we have just a really really
interesting and kind of crazy position
because white's so centralized but these
two bishops
have so much potential in open positions
and i can't stress that enough
if the two bishops can get kind of out
and get really working
they can be particularly nasty and then
that's kind of what happens so grishok
plays a5
again i don't know if it's so much about
pushing the pawn it's more about taking
away
squares for the pieces so for example
there's no
piece coming to b4 anymore there's no
i don't know i mean it's one of those
kind of slightly odd moves it also gives
the bishop a square so now the bishop
has the a6 square and i think that's the
main purpose of this move to be
perfectly honest
that having bishop a6 as a resource is
actually kind of nice
um but okay here
there was actually an interesting choice
so i'm kind of curious what you guys
would do here because i think alexinko's
move
i remarked about knight d1 being a bit
of a slow move i feel like his next move
is also a bit of a slow move
although again it's i wouldn't call it
bad right like i think
almost every the thing with positions
like this is they're actually very much
within the draw zone we would say
meaning that
you can make a slightly small mistake
and it's not going to cost you too much
just yet even though it is
there's a lot of potential in the
position like things are still
kind of on the even side so i don't
think one small mistake should cost
white the game or black
but i would definitely say that if you
make a couple of them you could end up
really compromising your position
so what would you guys do here i'm
actually kind of kind of curious
because white had a very very
interesting possibility here which i
think maybe
i would have gone for personally i don't
know
so what do you guys think
i agree chess king i think rook b7 is
very interesting
yeah rip two again is is is okay but
it's also kind of
simplistic and also like the problem
with oops the problem with rook d2
is that now you have to watch out for
bishop g5 moves again and i think bishop
g5 may even be a legitimate move here
because you don't really want to allow
the pawn to go to d2 right
so rook b7
is actually really really interesting
you allow bishop takes a2 but in return
you get this pesky d-pawn
but quite honestly i'm not really sure
what's going on here in general for
white i really like taking this d-pawn
because i think it frees your position
but maybe black can play a move like
rook c1 here with the idea of bishop b1
and this actually is quite annoying
so maybe this was a possibility like
even moves like rook g3 are on the
or in the air here but it's kind of
weird like black gets some strange
coordination
but they're only playing with the rook
and piece right because the rook on e8
and the bishop on d8 really aren't doing
much
so i'm not exactly sure what's happening
but it feels like it's
at least a possibility i don't know
uh but okay so in this position
uh instead he did play a3
which doug suggested basically trying to
play rook b7 but safeguarding the pawn
first
uh the issue with this move however is
that it is again is very slow
but this is where things are very
strange so grishok played the move g6
which is again a move i'm not so sure
about
it i kind of get it you want to prevent
knight f5 but it's a very committal move
as well because it does give up some
squares and
your dark squares could really become a
little bit iffy
uh but black had a very very interesting
possibility here which i think was
maybe missed at least by by one of the
players but possibly by both
um so i'm kind of curious what you guys
think about it
so what would you do here as black
black to move
so you have to think about it this way
you're really trying to exploit white's
king position a little bit
and you're trying to coordinate your
pieces
so chess king a move like bishop c7 or
bishop e7 looks very tempting
but there's actually a big problem with
it let's say we play bishop e7
i think that there's a big problem with
this move in fact
yes knight f5 and all of a sudden bishop
takes d6 as an
issue uh like knight rather bishop takes
d6 knight takes d6 maybe you can try
bishop f8 but this looks
very very sketchy because here for
example even if i just play bishop takes
bishop you can't take with a rook
because of knight check
so you have to take with the king and
now rook b7
and i don't know this looks very like a
knight coming into d6 actually you could
play knight d6 immediately as well
this is maybe simpler and this
looks very very irritating to say the
least
so this is just not a good thing to
allow and the same goes with bishop c7
right
bishop c7 you play knight f5 and it's
just too many threats it's too annoying
so sylvester had the right idea you
actually play
bishop f6 and this move is
really really tricky because at first
i i looked at this move but i didn't
quite understand it myself i must admit
so
it was one of those where i had to look
at it a lot deeper to kind of figure out
what was going on
but the main point is that bishop takes
e5 and rook c5 is actually a very nasty
threat
for example uh okay like if you try to
play rook b7 which is a reasonable try
here you can actually play rook d6 and
you're noticing this bishop on d4
d6 is actually all of a sudden a
weakness all of a sudden that bishop
has problems and it's because the king
on e4 even though it looks great because
it's centralized it's actually
not good because there's this huge pin
and actually white's already in trouble
because you can't move the bishop due to
bishop d5 check right
so bishop f6 actually seems really
really annoying
and if you play rook b6 to try to guard
your bishop to try to avoid that kind of
thing
now i can play bishop takes e5 rook c5
you have to guard your bishop and now i
play bishop here
takes the knight king takes bishop takes
but luckily for white they can still
draw this is probably what
should have happened if this went if
black played this
you'd play rook b8 and this end game
should be a draw
although white's the one fighting for it
so bishop f4 is coming and at bishop f3
nice little last try this is a typical
endgame trick
because if you take then i play d2 and i
queen
so black has to play bishop back to f
white has to play bishop back to f4
takes but this end game should
definitely be drawn i mean opposite
bishops and white's king is very very
strong
so i think the clearest way to draw this
is by playing not king d4
uh or no sorry it is king d4 if you play
king b5
i think white actually black actually
just brings their king to the center and
then this king can help support the
d-pawn
i still think this should be drawn but
it's at least a little bit trickier
so i think king d4 is best because now
you force the bishop back
and now you can play a4 and just go
after this pawn
and most likely because the apon is so
nasty probably black should actually
just go here
and we should shake hands after
something like this because this extra
pawn will not be one with right
so bishop f6 is like a really really
crazy
crazy move and again it's not that it's
like winning right but it forces white
to take a draw like right away
and maybe krishuk saw it and simply
didn't want white to be able to force
the draw
it's also possible i should point out
that after rook b6 you don't have to
play takes on e5 right away
but it is your main idea so i think that
once again maybe grishok wanted to try
to keep chances alive so he played g6
and to his credit it actually did work
out for him so rook b7
he plays bishop f6 now but now it's a
little bit different because you don't
white already has the rook on b7 so
you're not really
you're not really in time to do any of
this right so for example here
if you try to play rook d8 i think i can
just sidestep you with king f4
and you're not really doing much of
anything whereas another position
just to contrast for you guys if bishop
f6 here
and you go for the same line that i
showed you king f4 doesn't work because
you can simply take this bishop
and if you take then i take on the
knight so because the
d4 kind of hangs this is uh this
whole tempo really matters so if you
guys can take away anything from this
it's that you have to be very quick
especially in a tactical position
it's very possible maybe grishok just
thought like he could outplay him and
again i think he more thought that not
that alexenko is a weak player because
he's by no means weak
but more that he has to try to outplay
him because he needs to win this game
um so he plays bishop g7 here
and here i don't know i i would have
probably tried something like h4 for
white with the idea that
now if a move like rook c6 you sidestep
with king f4
and the whole point is that now you can
play knight g5 to block bishop h6 check
ideas the it's kind of hard to crack
white's position now
but it's kind of a tricky position
because i don't think white has any
major improving moves and those
positions are always really tricky
because you have to find a move that
doesn't harm your position
he plays rook a7 which definitely makes
a lot of sense
but it does allow black a very very
strong possibility which i think he
neglected to play
so what possibility does black have now
which is maybe quite good
what do you guys think
a4 is very interesting but it also
doesn't really force anything like i
think white has pl
several options after a4 because yes the
idea of a4 right is that if you play a4
and i play rook takes pawn you can play
bishop b3
and fork the rooks and you look very
smart
the drawback with a4 is that it's again
a slower move so white does have an
opportunity
to play something like i'm not exactly
sure what you try
but maybe a move like rook b1 would be
dangerous because now rook b7 is no joke
that's a very dangerous move
so i don't know this might pose some
problems for black in fact
so i mean you can try blocking the rook
but then i can take your pawn oh no i
can't take your pawn aha
maybe this is a good move but now i can
play knight d4 and hit your bishop maybe
but then d2
oh no this is probably too dangerous
yeah so maybe bishop e3 is too strong
after that that's a good point
so you guys are mentioning rook cda
threatening the bishop
that's what he played in the game but i
think that it actually wasn't maybe the
best move
and we'll get to that in a moment but
let's see a4 because actually this is
quite tricky
um what would i do
here
maybe knight d2 is not so silly
because i'm just trying to get this
bishop out of my face basically
because that bishop is just annoying me
uh quite a bit so i'm just trying to get
the bishop away
trying to get it so it doesn't bother me
so much anymore so maybe this is
actually a decent move
and what i like about this is because
i'm attacking the bishop you don't have
time to attack my bishop on d6
so maybe knight e2 is actually quite
decent here what do you guys think
so yeah maybe a4 is a bit slow but again
like i would say that one habit you guys
want to get into is you want to look at
your forcing moves before you look at
moves like a4 because a4 might be a
great move
but it's also slower so you want to look
at a4
after you look at moves that are
attacking moves and i would say that
there's a very very strong attacking
move
maybe but i feel like when the bishop
gets to b3 knight d2 is going to be
harder to make work
but knights two immediately i think
works pretty well
so what can we try here as black again
look for forcing moves right
bishop e3 very nice so you play bishop
b3
and i think white should sack the
exchange because if you play the move
rook d2
and i play bishop c2 the problem is that
bishop h6 is coming and you're probably
gonna have to lose that rook anyway
because there's just no real there's no
real course
of action that like you can't really do
anything to black here and once you play
once you allow this it could be very
very dangerous
um so i don't think rook d2 actually
helps you so you probably have to take
this pawn and allow bishop c2
i should point out that the taking the
exchange is not really the end of the
world
the bigger problem that white faces here
is that his pieces are very
discoordinated in fact
so for example if you play the move king
d4 if you were to take this rook
then king takes bishop and i don't
really think white's doing so badly here
you can take on a5 you can bring your
king back
i don't see why white would be unhappy
here the problem is that black can play
a move like rook c6
and believe it or not the king just has
no good square
you're threatening to take this bishop
with check and the king just doesn't
have a safe square
which is quite funny so a move like rook
c6 would actually be quite nice
rook d8 is also possible but it allows
the king to escape to the c file you
could play king c3 for instance and
i think that that would be like
something they wouldn't want to allow so
rick c6 is kind of a clever version of
that um
in any case i don't think king d4 is
best i think king e3 is better
so you've provoked bishop h6 check then
king d4 because now because there's no
pin
on your pawn your rook dc6 doesn't
threaten anything
so black would have to take and takes
and again i think because of these
the pawn and bishop it's
quite good compensation here again i
still think black could have gone for
this like this
it feels like a better option at least
maybe you can play with bishop f8 try to
trade off the bishop
like a rook d8 next for example it at
least feels like a better choice right
um but i don't know i mean
it was at least something to consider i
think he just didn't
one thing you'll notice with gm's in
general is that we don't mind slacking
exchanges at all and especially if we
have a pawn on e5 and rook on bishop on
d6
so it could be that he just felt that
that position is not good enough you
know that he
maybe even if he's better he's not gonna
be able to win
which is fair enough he chose rook cd8
instead and here i think after king f4
white's kind of doing okay
uh it definitely has a dangerous feel to
it but at the same time
it's not so easy like it it feels wrong
to have to move your king out of the
center
but the fact is that as you guys notice
the king on d4 the king on e4 it's
actually not that great it's one of the
few cases where
bringing the king in the center can
actually cause you to
go wrong and that's exactly what
happened he played
king d4 threatening the bishop
but now after bishop b3 all of a sudden
the rook and bishop are both hanging
so alexinko of course had a plan for
this he was planning to sack the
exchange here
and sack it for a position where he has
opposite bishops
and this is also quite interesting i i
will say that
it's one of those positions again where
i think with most accurate play
black can maybe get something but it's
very very difficult in practice
yes the palo veronian yes i remember uh
i picked it
was that the game topolo sack 2
exchanges
or was that a run-in i don't remember
but yeah there are there are quite a few
um but the paula was famous for it
because he he was willing to sacrifice
an exchange
without anything too concrete for it he
would just do it because he thought
practically it was quite good
um and of course the first one who
really did it a lot was uh petr
petrarcian he was famous for a sake in
exchange for positional reasons
uh but the fact is now it's just a very
common thing in a gm's arsenal so almost
any gm
like knows how to sack the exchange and
knows like when it's decent when it's
not
and kind of has the feel for that so
it's just one of the things you want to
learn to get good at
and i don't just mean only gm's do it
right like every every player kind of
can learn it
but it's a good skill to learn because i
think that a lot of the times especially
of a position like this
the two bishops are so annoying and so
nasty that sacrifice in exchange for a
dangerous pawn
is actually worthwhile because here let
me put it this way i think that black is
probably better with best play
but because there's no more dark square
bishop the king can sit pretty on d4
and never be unsafe the pawn on e5 and
bishop and d6 control so many squares
to actually win this position from a
practical point of view is so difficult
even if you think you're better here
and to give you an idea i think that in
this position grishok already plays a
slight error
and i think it's kind of almost a logic
error in my opinion
more than anything else so i'm curious
what you guys would play here as black
thank you
so what would you guys try because i
think that it's a position where the
best move is
not altogether obvious
um
so a4 is what you guys thought right
away and this was also grishak's move
um and i think it's a mistake
and i'll show you why in a moment but
what else have you guys got
uh i would love to play rook c8 but at
the moment rook c8 runs into rook takes
b3 so you need to deal with your bishop
hanging first
so a move like this i find an invaluable
tool
is processes of elimination so
first up let me ask you a different
question
if you're white here what piece are you
most looking to improve
what piece is definitely not the best
here
bishop c2 is possible i don't hate
bishop z2 i'll tell you that
but you have to keep in mind yes so doug
has it right which is that the knight on
f3 is really not the best piece
it looks nice but the fact is it like
the e pawns defended the king doesn't
need to be defended the knight does
nothing there
the knight would love to move to d2 to
e4 to f6
so given that the move a4 i think is bad
because it allows 92 a tempo
so a move like bishop g e6 looks logical
but that allows knight g5 with tempo
because now this knight is just annoying
and if you play a move like h6 then i'm
happy to go to e4
uh if i need to um
i could consider taking the bishop as
well by the way but
so you're kind of walking into 90s
knight g5 with tempo
bishop c2 makes a lot of sense but
you're also forcing me to improve my
rook and i'm not so sure your bishop
belongs there
so for example a move like rook c3 looks
a little annoying
and now if you try rook c8 maybe even
bishop c7 and a5 hangs
i don't know
so believe it or not i actually like the
move
as bishop g8 and the whole point is that
now rook c8 is coming
and knight g5 does not come with tempo
in any way shape or form
and rook c3 is met very clearly by rook
c8 so if rook c3 you play rook c8
and this is now possible but there's no
bishop hanging on c2
so if you need to you have the time to
play a4
and now you don't have to worry about
the the pawn hanging
so i think that bishop g8 is actually
very very
a very very nice move but not altogether
obvious so i moved like a4 is easy to
play quickly because you want to secure
your bishop
but the problem is now the knight
improves with tempo because now the
bishop has to move
the bishop moves and now knight e4 and
here i think that white's already
getting
oodles of counter play because they got
a night move for free
so sometimes these positions are all
about that one or two details
so grishok plays bishop f5
and here rook c3 is actually
a very desirable move but unfortunately
after bishop takes e4
you uh just lose because you can okay
you can play rook c7 check
but after king up king takes bishop you
still walk into this
that would be very unfortunate so
instead he plays the move rook e3
and here bishop takes e4 rook takes e4
so once again we end up in a very very
complex end game lights down the
exchange for a pawn
but here his centralized king his bishop
on d6 is pawn on e5
these pieces are so so good
and when you have pieces like this even
when you're down the exchange
it's just so difficult for your opponent
to play
and i would say that it's just it's just
really tough
so this kind of position i feel like
it's one of those where
there's a practical element to it and
then there's an objective element i
would say objectively
black is you know fine and black's maybe
even a tad better in some lines or
whatever although it's very close to
equal
but at least from a practical point of
view playing this for black
is very difficult because you have to
deal with the centralized king you have
to deal with this powerful epon
so it's just a type of position i would
really like to avoid
and i feel like if black had kept more
pieces on the board they would have had
more of an opportunity
to try to make black white's king feel
uncomfortable in the center you notice
all those lines where the king was
feeling uncomfortable now
they don't really have that opportunity
so this position actually becomes very
very tricky
so grishok plays rook f8 which is kind
of clever he's using the pin to activate
his rook
the only problem is now there's nothing
blockading that e pawn
so white plays king e3 it looks a little
funny but he's trying to play rook takes
a4 at some point
so then the rook goes back to e8 and
here rook takes a4
runs into of course rook d6 again so he
plays king f4 instead
8 rook b4
rook a7 and now the king comes marching
back
king f7 and here there are different
options king d5 is an option he chooses
rook b6
to prevent the king from going to e6
because king on e6 would be a very very
good block hater
so he tries rook c8 bishop to b4
and rook ac7 so he's actually
surrendering to the fact that he can't
block the e pawn blocking the epon will
be an ultimate success
but he just really can't quite do it
white plays king d5
and now e6 check is coming so black
chooses to activate his rooks instead
so he plays rook c2 this is very risky
looking but the fact is he's trying to
activate his rooks and basically say
that you're not going to queen the
e-pawn i can defend against it long
enough
but once again this kind of position is
so so difficult
it's really really complex to play and
really really difficult
so he plays e6 check and here once again
it's one of those positions where
it still looks really dangerous but if
you turn on the computer it says every
single move is a dead draw
but from a human perspective at least
this is such a difficult position to
play
so it's just something to remember
because a lot of people will look at the
computer evaluations and think okay it's
just a dead draw
but the fact is that for human beings
it's very difficult like for me the move
king e8 looks suicidal
but the fact is it's still a draw
because the best white can do is rook b7
and now black plays this and then check
and then this and then here
so this is one way the game could end
they could play king to g8
and now you can play king d6 for example
rook takes g2
king d7 and this is another thing once
you get a pawn on e7 defended by a
bishop
it's worth an exchange like even though
it's
down a full exchange now that pawn on e7
is a monster
but the fact is that after king f7
the best white can do here is to just
play rookie 6. this is a funny move
because you're threatening rookie 8
which is
e8 queen sorry which is very strong
notice how the bishop guards the d6
square very important
or the d2 square so the best black has
here is check
white goes to d8 now threatening queen
again and then
this kind of weird perpetual so
basically everything ends in a draw but
as we know grishok was trying to win
this right so he plays king f6
rook b7 g5 so
moves like rook d8 don't do anything
because i can actually play rook d7
and it's quite an embarrassing situation
after takes takes
this bishop controls all the squares and
this pawn's going to queen with check
right
so because the pawn is going to queen
with check you actually just resign here
which is very very sad
so g5 was played in the game notice how
rook f7 check would be very nasty
potentially
so he plays g5 rook takes h7
rook takes g2 and again the mess
continues
king d6 king g6
rook back to h3 here you have choices
you could bring the rook out the other
way but rook h3 actually makes a lot of
sense to me
because you want to try to improve your
rook somehow and sometimes bringing the
rook
in front of the paw or behind the pawn
is actually a really good thing
so this position actually was a bit
confusing to me again
the move grishook played this is again
where i don't like computer because i
of course i checked my analysis it's
such a complex position
um that i wanted to check my analysis
and what i found funny was i thought
greeschuk's move here for sure was a
mistake and computer just doesn't care
it thinks it's fine
but i think from a human perspective his
move is a slight mistake so what would
you guys play as black here
because for me i definitely had a clear
favorite move
um to be fair i was also trying to draw
and not not
win so maybe that was part of it but how
would you guys play as black hair
yeah rookie two this is the move i like
as well
because i want to get my rook behind the
pawn to ensure that bad boy does not
queen
so after e7 for example i play rook a8
and if king d7 i check and i don't think
that white ever is going to win this
because the the two rooks actually do an
excellent job guarding against the e
pawn
so for me playing rookie 2 is just a
very natural thing because i just don't
want this panda queen
in the game however he played the move
g4
so he's forcing stuff but it allows to
move rookie three by white and i think
this is just too annoying now all of a
sudden you can definitely lose that epon
is very very strong
but once again i think that grishok was
still keeping in mind that he wanted to
he wanted to win and that sometimes
skews how you play a position
and i would say that unless you're in
truly a must-win game you want to make
sure you view the position objectively
because
you know if you try to win a position
where you should be trying to draw
it's very likely you just lose because
you're going to play too ambitiously
and in the end it just costs you and
that's really what happens here he plays
rook takes h2
white plays king d7 and here once again
you have to kind of decide your
defensive setup
and it's a very difficult thing to do
because this e pawn's just getting
shoved in right
and because it's supported by this
beautiful king on d7 the bishop on b4
and rook on e3 are very strong
you have to kind of defend against it in
an odd way but i do think it's very
important and this is a true of a rook
and game concept too
where do you think the c8 rook should go
in general
where should it go in general
to a8 i agree and then to me this is
like the third
the the three file defense or whatever
you want to call it
right the the against an a pawn because
the whole point is that after e7 you
want to be able to check the king in a
lot of cases now here
i would be careful because if you start
checking the king to prematurely i'm
going to do this and the e pawn's going
to queen now
so you have to play rook h7 first to
create a pin
but the whole point is that now it's
very very annoying to actually queen
that e pawn
so after something like bishop c5 trying
to prevent rook a7 check
i play king f6 and again there are many
many options i just want to show you
kind of a sample variation here
rookie 1 king f5 and the whole idea is
that i want to advance my king
so the whole point is you can't go to f8
because i'm going to take you so you
have to play something like king c6
and now i can play rook c8 check
rookie 8 rook a8 and it's just really
really hard to make progress here
because the rook on h7 pins the pawn and
the rook on a8 guards
everything so it's just a very tricky
position to make progress
but i think this was what black should
have tried in the game he played rook
h8 which i don't know i think it's a
little bit passive i think the rook on
h7 is often going to be stronger than
the rook on h8
so alexinko plays e7
and here once again i think he could
have tried king f5
the main idea is that if a move like
bishop d6 you play rook a8 it doesn't
change much
and if you try queening i'm gonna be
just too fast because i can play rook
takes c8
rook takes c8 rook takes a king takes e8
and now the plan is to get the king to
b3 so i play king e6
notice how i'm shouldering i'm not going
this way
right because that would allow something
like this maybe so i'm going here to
keep this king
out of the game and now i'm pushing
and going for this so you force bishop
c5 you attack the bishop
and the whole point here is that no
matter what happens for black's white's
bishop you force the bishop here and
then queen
and you separate it from the a pawn this
is a common drawing technique
so i think that king f5 would have drawn
but notice how black has to be very
careful and already be trying to draw
but you also see how much leeway there
is in a chess game
we've shown a bunch of mistakes some of
them maybe technically aren't big
mistakes
and overall these guys have played a
really nice game it's really hard to
play these kind of positions but i would
also say that
you know you get a lot of opportunities
but you have to calculate one of them
accurately because at some point the
opportunities run out
so black plays here which i think is
already asking for it a bit bishop d6
which is a nice move trying to guard
against the g pawn
so here if rookie if king of five for
example
rookie five check i think is quite
decent with the idea that if king f6 you
go here
and you fork the pawns so they actually
have to go up which looks crazy
but now you check and here it gets just
really crazy the main line i have goes
king e3
taking the pawn rook g8
rook b4 the problem is it takes then you
take here and that's the draw
so here rook a8 a4 king d2
so the ideas are tightening to push the
pawn rook f4
and now you pin and maybe black's
holding on
but this is very difficult to find for
any human being this is obviously not a
human line but just to show you how
complex this gets
you have to find all these crazy moves
so rk8 was played
and here white plays bishop c7
here queening is actually much closer
but i think it's still a draw like
i looked into this a while and the basic
idea is that you just keep back here
you don't want to go for king e4 now
because if you try to go for this you're
just going to lose because i take the
pawn for free
so you actually want to play king f6 and
the idea is that you just wait with the
king and your object
is to basically go for this corner so
you do this and go for the
a8 corner and i don't think there's a
great way to stop you so that probably
should end in a draw
but it's also not simple right like even
after analyzing this like it's not
completely obvious that you should draw
but i think it's just enough so instead
white plays bishop c7 notice how even
alexenko even though he
doesn't have a shot at first place in
the tournament is still really doing his
best to win and this is a common theme
right that like
even if you're out of the tournament
even if you're in the bottom places you
still want to be fighting as much as you
can
to get those points and he really wanted
this full point and to his credit he
really got it
so once again i think rook h7 maybe is a
better defense he plays rook g8
rook e4 rook czech rook takes a4 and
here i thought his technique was really
really nice
so if rook h7 here you can play bishop
g3 and simply blockade the pawn
king h4 he tried so rook e4
a4 so notice he can't play queen yet
because
if he tries to queen you run into
rook takes and then rook takes and this
should be a draw on end game
it's still tricky to to sometimes draw
like this but obviously that's not what
he wants so he plays a4
h a5 and notice the pawn still can't
advance so easily
so rook h7 king c6
they repeat a couple times but then he
goes here and again maybe black could
have shown better defense but it's still
pretty losing here
he plays rookie 8 king d7
rook czech brook back and now he's
simply going to snack on that pawn
but bishop d8 is a nice kind of final
touch
the idea being that if you try to play
rook takes e7 i can take with check and
play
behind the pawn and this should be an
easy win
if you try taking this bishop i take
with check
and so you can't you can't try any
shenanigans here actually the
shenanigans wouldn't work anyway but
this is completely winning of course
so he plays king f5 and now
he takes the rook and plays king f8 and
that is all she wrote because there's no
way to stop the epon queening with check
so overall just a really really nice
game by alexinko
um and just
an example of what can happen if you try
to push too hard but in general just a
really fascinating game a really
interesting end game that could have
gone either way
um so i hope you enjoyed the game i hope
you enjoyed the analysis
uh this week on thursday i will not be
doing your
youtube classes uh talia will be doing
that because i'll be doing commentary
for something else
but uh but enjoy that and in general
i'll be here next week
so i will see you guys then and have a
good night
or morning or whatever it is where you
are